Hi, I'm Nick's brother, Bob.
Nick's been a little busy. He's gone
through one of those depressions he goes
through and he's reading all these
self-help books about how to sublimate
trauma ruminations into affirmations of
positive self-worth. And I thought,
well, maybe I'll go help him make some
videos cuz I know a little ploy myself.
And this video is going to be about all
you who are learning how to do in spin
and anti- spin. uh because that can be a
long journey and some people get a
little frustrated in process and it's
all about enjoying the circles you make
and making happy circles because you got
your poi. You probably can make a circle
like this but doing a poi flower means
you got to make those circles through a
full range of motion and you might find
that when you reach up high or off to
the side your planes go all effing all
over the place and you might get
frustrated. But the thing is, the way
you approach poi now is going to be the
way you approach poi for your whole
journey with poi. And if you enjoy this
process now, you're going to enjoy it
later on, too. It's not going to become
more fun later on when you get better.
Maybe you go there and they go a little
wonky. But you know what the heck? Make
wonky circles. And a little bit by
little bit, you're going to make those
circles on a plane for a whole range of
motion.
And if your arm, if it goes in the same
direction as the poi, well, that's going
to become your your in spin patterns.
And a harder one is making your arm go
the other direction. And that's going to
become your anti- spin. Now, you might
ask yourself, why do you want to make
those anti- spin patterns anyway? You
want to do P well, so you can spin play
better than other people.
If so, why do you want to spin play
better than other people? How is that
going to make other people feel?
Or do you want to spin pi the best you
can every day that you spin poi?
Because you know what kind of people I
want to hang out with are the ones who
just want to be the best version of
themselves every day rather than
worrying about whether they're better
than other people. Cuz you know, people
who want to be better than other people,
well, they kind of suck balls.
So I say just be the best you can be and
make uh the happiest circles you can
make today.
Thing is, you know, for a lot of us PO
spinners, we like the early days because
in the early days you could learn so
much every time you practice. So some
people even kind of wish they could go
back and enjoy those first year or two
of PO when there was so much to learn.
It was so easy to learn it. So enjoy
that now. So I hope you enjoy this
video. Hope you have a nice happy day.
Hope you spin some happy circles.